قنبلة تنفجر وسوف تدمر
ومن سيتسبب في أضرار جانبية
سوف يقتل بلا شك الأطفال ولكن هؤلاء
لن يموت الأطفال من وجود
الانطباع بأن الإنسانية أمامهم
لقد خانوا كل ما يحق لهم
الانتظار هناك ما هو فظيع
لتخيل هؤلاء الأطفال الذين كانوا 8 9
10 سنوات هؤلاء النساء الذين غادروا
أخذ كصورة أخيرة صورة
من الوحشية والوحشية والازدراء
تلك التي هم اه هذا حيث هذا
جريمة متخصصة ضد الإنسانية
النفي المطلق وأعتقد أننا
سوف تستفيد من شرح ذلك كثيرا
أكثر لأنه خلاف ذلك ملكة
العاطفة تضع علامات المساواة بين
جميع الضحايا ولكن هذا صحيح واحد
الموت الفلسطيني هو الموت الإسرائيلي
تبقى حالتان وفاة ولكن الطريقة التي
لقد قتلوا وهي هي
مختلفة ويبدأ من لدينا
اللاإنسانية أو لدينا
إنسانية